your early days in Chicago you had this
killer mustache and so what I mean
people like the mustache for the
mustache ever come back the mustache was
my signature look in 1999 it was working
at the station in Chicago and you know
the ratings were bad and I'd kind of got
demoted and I was at this point in life
what do I want to do and I said I'm
gonna go find another job so I knew that
I was gonna get this break and normally
in what we do you don't want to mess
with your appearance whatever you got
going right you stay you know you look
like it's a French pastry you don't want
to miss you don't want to mess with your
lord clay but I had this window of
opportunity so I decided to shave off
the mustache and then when I was
interviewing at MSNBC at the time they
said well we looked at your tapes you
had a mustache tonight you don't have a
mustache now and I said well if you hire
me it's your choice and they said no we
like you without the mustache so right
do you think it ever could now you've
got the big job you think you'd ever
grow it back I don't think so you know
you could get a glue on one and it could
be on some nights and off other nights
and people would be tuning in like butch
Lester is it tonight the gray got to be
an issue with it and then trimming it
and trying to make it even it was just I
tell you my moustache idea is a killer
tell the gang at NBC Conan's got some
big ideas for him
you